so liz uh you will be uh eliminating
all of the personal trainer jobs the
united states how does that feel to get
all of those jobs to be wiped out
because of this technology it's so funny
that's a that's like the question
right no no robots will not take my job
this actually gives me an opportunity to
reach even more people and to share what
i love and share what i'm passionate
about
with even more people there are not
enough personal training jobs
out there so this is so nice to be able
to give access to people
who wouldn't otherwise be able to access
me
that is a perfectly rehearsed pr answer
it's and it's perfect i thought that was
incredibly well done no it's true
there are most people in the united
states don't have access to personal
trainers anyway they live in an area or
it's
out of reach for them on an expense
basis but this is going to come down in
cost if it's three thousand and fifty
dollars now
i'm guessing after two or three versions
of this you're going to be able to lower
the cost over time
yeah i mean that the the goal here is to
get this into the hands of as many
people
so 29.95 for the hardware we also have
financing plans
um which allow people to to spread the
payments over 24 months
uh and then we're looking for more and
more ways to make this more affordable
for more people putting it in gyms and
starting your own like little gyms with
these in them have you thought about
that we have
we have thought about that all right